the latest economic numbers show
inflation is slowing down but not for
people who buy eggs the average price
for a dozen of eggs has more than
doubled over the past year shortages
around the country are hurting producers
and putting more stress on consumers and
businesses Carter Evans reports from
hard hit California
a breakfast spot in Los Angeles that
goes through up to 6 000 eggs a week
costs have quadrupled and they're
feeling it all of our courses are made
with eggs Nationwide prices for grade A
eggs are up 137 percent from last year
to an average of 425 a dozen meanwhile
the line of cars is about 30 minutes
long at Billy's Egg farm in Southern
California you couldn't find eggs in the
grocery store so
um I've been coming ever since and
workers are scrambling to meet demand we
pack eggs in here eight to four o'clock
non-stop co-owner Billy Mao sells 25
000 fresh eggs a day for five dollars a
dozen that's a pretty good bargain right
now grocery stores are seven to nine
dollars a dozen that's if you can find
them this is what a lot of store shelves
here look like why is there a shortage
right now what's going on well I'm sure
you heard there is a bird flu in the
Midwest and most of the eggs that come
to our grocery stores here in California
come from the Midwest so far almost 58
million birds in the U.S have been
infected or euthanized it's the
country's worst outbreak ever the
unfortunate reality with this particular
strain of the bird flu is that it seems
to be potentially endemic in wild birds
meaning it could be here to stay but the
American egg board says inflation is an
even bigger part of the problem no
problem and there's another factor in
California all eggs sold in State now
have to come from cage-free chickens
like Billy Mouse it's expensive it's
about 20 to 25 dollars per bird to
switch over to cage-free and with Easter
on the way it could be some time before
these high egg prices begin to crack
for CBS warnings Carter Evans Los
Angeles